Caption: [Applause]
Caption: thanks Alex so easy to do this get a sec
Caption: cool Sertoma talk is forgetting your
Caption: passwords with the web authentication
Caption: API there's my twitter handle and hash
Caption: tags and all that kind of thing because
Caption: that's what we do these days who has
Caption: heard of the web authentication API
Caption: that's a lot of people I thought who has
Caption: used it too all right
Caption: and have you used it in production you
Caption: have Wow okay you maybe should be doing
Caption: this talk because I haven't yeah so who
Caption: had a chance to look at that demo while
Caption: you're waiting filtering in and that's
Caption: what five-ten did it work
Caption: great do you have iPhones great ok we'll
Caption: talk about that but we couldn't be here
Caption: today without our sponsors there are a
Caption: whole bunch of them they all give money
Caption: and without them this conference
Caption: wouldn't happen or if it didn't it cost
Caption: you a lot more than $60 so thanks to
Caption: them and the volunteers and the other
Caption: speakers and committee members lots of
Caption: people go into this day and it's a big
Caption: one so what we're going to talk about
Caption: today is I guess we're gonna set a
Caption: little bit of a make sure everyone's on
Caption: the same page we'll talk about what
Caption: authentication is why passwords are bad
Caption: and why would you try and get rid of
Caption: them
Caption: the web authentication if you I am how
Caption: that helps us get rid of passwords and
Caption: then talk about what that means in terms
Caption: of what we're gonna build for our users
Caption: so first of all authentication is about
Caption: proving your identity that can happen
Caption: through three ways at the moment we've
Caption: got something you know which is usually
Caption: a password or PIN number something you
Caption: have like your phone you get a text
Caption: message or something you which would be
Caption: your fingerprint or your facial
Caption: recognition this kind of thing and the
Caption: way authentication works is we'll start
Caption: off with a gibe like Dave and Dave wants
Caption: to get into a club so he meets the
Caption: bouncer when he gets to the front of
Caption: line the bouncer says hold on a second
Caption: mate dad guys here's my ID the bouncer
Caption: has a look at that
Caption: looks at a few things on it and says
Caption: alright you're good to go that's I've
Caption: verified who you are that's not quite or
Caption: fit authorization that's the
Caption: authentication part of it so at this
Caption: point he knows that you are who it says
Caption: on a card
Caption: but he doesn't know if you're allowed
Caption: and that's going to be decided on things
Caption: like your age whether you're drunk
Caption: already if you're on a list or if you're
Caption: wearing the right shoes and the
Caption: important part of this exchange is the
Caption: ID and the IDE has a few things on it
Caption: that help us know that it's only
Caption: improves who you are it's issued by for
Caption: example the Department of Transport
Caption: it's got Holograms and that kind of
Caption: thing and it's got a picture of you and
Caption: we're looking at that picture and
Caption: knowing that you trust the document
Caption: itself you can trust that the person is
Caption: you let's say they are that's part of
Caption: the same thing we have with passwords
Caption: where it's something that I know and I
Caption: give to you and you can validate that
Caption: that's right password
Caption: oh isn't if you're a server on the other
Caption: let's say yeah but passwords are really
Caption: bad for people to actually use you know
Caption: we're not good at creating passwords the
Caption: top ten passwords that are most
Caption: frequently used are all crap and I mean
Caption: one two three four five six you you
Caption: wouldn't have a hard time guessing that
Caption: oh I suppose password I don't know the
Caption: one that I'm not sure about on there is
Caption: dragon number ten but between those ten
Caption: passwords that covers like one point six
Caption: percent of accounts which sounds like a
Caption: small number but if you think of
Caption: Facebook with three or four billion
Caption: accounts one point six percent is many
Caption: millions so you know you don't need to
Caption: try a lot of passwords to get into a lot
Caption: of accounts but you go yeah passwords on
Caption: that list and that's a really bad
Caption: posture I know that you know I know that
Caption: I need to have a capital letter or I
Caption: need to put a number on the end or maybe
Caption: I replace one of the numbers do a symbol
Caption: and now I've got a good password it's
Caption: all the complexity rules so those don't
Caption: really help either because you end up
Caption: with passwords like this and then you
Caption: have things like forced password changes
Caption: you know let's say you're in a corporate
Caption: environment a lot of the time you'll
Caption: need to change your password every three
Caption: months so what do you do then you change
Caption: that number from a one to a two
Caption: and every three months you know you've
Caption: been with the company you divide that
Caption: number by four and find out how long you
Caption: been there we're not very good at
Caption: remembering passwords either you know we
Caption: all know that we need to make different
Caption: passwords for every count but I reuse
Caption: passwords all the time and 60% of people
Caption: will admit to it also and password
Caption: resets if you do forget they're really
Caption: slow they're expensive you know kind of
Caption: making having to call a help desk or sit
Caption: on a help desk and ask for a password
Caption: reset all day every day
Caption: so passwords are bad for everyone really
Caption: they're involved in things like data
Caption: breaches where your password gets leaked
Caption: anyway we reuse that password so if I
Caption: get on one site they can use it
Caption: everywhere
Caption: we'll use common passwords even if
Caption: you're not in a breach there's a
Caption: reasonable chance you can get in and
Caption: then you have things like phishing
Caption: attacks where I can just get your
Caption: password like that and all of those
Caption: problems come down to the password being
Caption: a shared secret something that both
Caption: parties need to know the person joined a
Caption: login for example and the server itself
Caption: so do you think you can trust all the
Caption: people with your secrets I don't but who
Caption: in the room wants to share a secret no
Caption: okay
Caption: 81% of all hacking related breaches come
Caption: from stolen passwords so that kind of
Caption: reinforces that maybe you can't trust
Caption: people with things that are secret and
Caption: then you get things like have I been
Caption: client and I've ended up on here a few
Caption: times who else wants to admit to it most
Caption: of the room so you know clearly we don't
Caption: we're not doing it all right and the way
Caption: we have traditionally dealt with
Caption: passwords as developers will go yeah I'm
Caption: not sure I know how to do it so I'll
Caption: just implement social login let's
Caption: Facebook store passwords yeah they know
Caption: what they're doing but do they Facebook
Caption: github twitter Microsoft Google they've
Caption: all had data breaches where passwords
Caption: have been exposed in plaintext often
Caption: that's when they're logging them in web
Caption: servers and that kind of thing so social
Caption: logins kind of out then well what about
Caption: yeah multi-factor authentication I go I
Caption: get an SMS every time I need to log into
Caption: a new device
Caption: and that's okay it's better than nothing
Caption: certainly but it's not perfect either
Caption: this guy Sean Koontz lost a hundred
Caption: grand in Bitcoin because someone stole
Caption: his password it's surprisingly easy to
Caption: do that I know I work for Telstra so
Caption: multi-factor authentication isn't great
Caption: either what if we didn't install
Caption: passwords at all that's where we end up
Caption: with the web authentication API the web
Caption: authentication API enables password list
Caption: authentication all simplifies using
Caption: multi-factor authentication and it does
Caption: this by delegating the responsibility
Caption: for authenticating a user to their own
Caption: device you don't need to do that
Caption: yourself you just get an assertion that
Caption: that person is who they say they are
Caption: from a device and what that means is if
Caption: we never have to send a secret over the
Caption: Internet
Caption: so how do you use it well you can use
Caption: one of these a Yubikey or similar please
Caption: go on but I did this offender the other
Caption: day and every one more people had their
Caption: hands up than I thought it there as well
Caption: so that was I don't know two dozen or so
Caption: whose mom has one okay so so it's a bit
Caption: of a challenge there what you call this
Caption: is an external Authenticator or a
Caption: cross-platform or a roaming
Caption: Authenticator how about a fingerprint or
Caption: I guess to be more specific a device
Caption: that lets you login with your
Caption: fingerprint like a phone a lot of people
Caption: whose mom has one of those I'm nice a
Caption: better number so to me that's where the
Caption: promise for this API actually comes from
Caption: these authenticators you can use your
Caption: Android phones or iPhones maybe as
Caption: authenticators in themselves so they
Caption: will actually prove that you are who you
Caption: say you are by using your fingerprint
Caption: and those are called internal or
Caption: platform or bound authenticators so for
Caption: those who didn't get to do the demo I'll
Caption: show you roughly what that looks like
Caption: and what what it means when you're
Caption: logging or what you have to do when
Caption: you're logging in using the web
Caption: authentication API so you start up on
Caption: this site for example web Wharton's are
Caption: higher
Caption: and I'll enter my email username and I
Caption: don't yet enter a password and I click
Caption: register I'll get a little prompt for my
Caption: browser telling me enter my security key
Caption: or if you do it on your final ask me
Caption: think fingerprint you probably have a
Caption: few prompts before that to say what kind
Caption: of care you want to use and then you you
Caption: touch it and you get to go if you log in
Caption: pretty much the same you just touch your
Caption: device so it's really simple you don't
Caption: need to worry about doing a whole lot of
Caption: validation of what that password is and
Caption: making sure your hashing it because if
Caption: there's no pass we're at the store so
Caption: have a look at what actually does get
Caption: sent around in this case the three main
Caption: parties are your Authenticator I've used
Caption: that symbol but I could just as easily
Caption: be your phone the browser and the
Caption: website server so you start off by
Caption: sending a username and maybe a password
Caption: because I said you can use multi-factor
Caption: authentication and then the server will
Caption: respond with a challenge and the
Caption: challenge is basically a sort of shared
Caption: secret but it's not a secret so it's
Caption: just something that both sides use at
Caption: the end it also sent back some details
Caption: about the the website itself like a
Caption: display name to display in those prompts
Caption: and since details about what kind of
Caption: authenticate is it'll actually that you
Caption: use you know are you gonna let people
Caption: use their phone or maybe you only let
Caption: people use those hardware ones basically
Caption: that gets passed on to the Authenticator
Caption: and then the fennec adder will do its
Caption: thing and you know you tap the button or
Caption: whatever and respond back with some more
Caption: data signature that needs to be verified
Caption: by the server credential ID and a public
Caption: key which needs to be stored above 0 so
Caption: let's go to the browser obviously you've
Caption: got to get them to a server so you do
Caption: that bit so now there are a few
Caption: different parties here and we have
Caption: different specs that actually define
Caption: what that is so there's the web
Caption: authentication API which you'll see
Caption: shortened as web orphan a lot because
Caption: typing out the web authentication API
Caption: takes a bit longer and that defines what
Caption: happens between your browser and the
Caption: website server I guess the JavaScript
Caption: website as well and then you have the
Caption: client Authenticator protocol which
Caption: talks from the client to the
Caption: Authenticator so that's from the browser
Caption: or your operating system
Caption: to the Authenticator itself and those
Caption: together form photo too so a lot of time
Caption: you'll look up and see flight o2 slicing
Caption: web forth and if you google or whatever
Caption: and I talked a bit about the magic that
Caption: the Authenticator does so we can have a
Caption: look a little bit of a look at that now
Caption: the Authenticator has three million
Caption: things that it does firstly it verifies
Caption: your identity and it does that through
Caption: possession and or a PIN number or a
Caption: biometric rating from that and that kind
Caption: of means you have two factors in one you
Caption: know we'll talk about two-factor
Caption: authentication being something you know
Caption: and something you have or some of you
Caption: are we've kind of already got that by
Caption: being able to press a button that proves
Caption: that you have it and by having a pin
Caption: that proves you know something or by
Caption: using a fingerprint proves that you are
Caption: something so you kind of get two factors
Caption: in one which is why you can use this as
Caption: a strong single factor then what the
Caption: credential does is stores a credential
Caption: and that credential is scoped to the
Caption: website that you've actually gone to it
Caption: stores you the URL and maybe a user ID
Caption: so you can login with multiple accounts
Caption: on one website and what that means is
Caption: that the credential won't be given to
Caption: the wrong website so if you have a
Caption: phishing website it won't get your your
Caption: transform information and even if it did
Caption: it's public anyway you know you have a
Caption: public here you're not sending a product
Caption: Kyocera so I'm gonna say that means it's
Caption: unfishable but I don't think you'll see
Caption: that written in any Docs because
Caption: security researchers I guess or wary of
Caption: when we call the Titanic an unsinkable
Caption: so take from that what you will
Caption: I'm gonna clean it but I'm not an
Caption: authority on that and that credential
Caption: itself is actually an asymmetric key
Caption: here so you have a private key which is
Caption: stored securely on the device never
Caption: leaves the device in it it's kind of by
Caption: definition it's private
Caption: and it sends the public key up to the
Caption: browser and then onto the server so how
Caption: does the public ke help you actually
Caption: verify your identity you might be more
Caption: familiar with using public keys for
Caption: messaging Corrections for example I
Caption: thought if I have two people Alice and
Caption: Bob
Caption: Alice wants to write a message
Caption: and Sam that's a bulb but also wants to
Caption: make sure that only Bob can read it so
Caption: he wants to encrypt it in the middle the
Caption: way we do that these days is with public
Caption: key cryptography so this recipient in
Caption: this case Bob will have his public key
Caption: in his private key he'll have to
Caption: generate them he doesn't have one and
Caption: you can use that public key to encrypt
Caption: the message and the private key to
Caption: decrypt the message that is okay but at
Caption: the moment Bob has his public key so if
Caption: you wanted to encrypt the message you
Caption: have to get it from Alice somehow anyway
Caption: which means you don't have encrypt it in
Caption: the middle so because it's a public key
Caption: Bob can give that to Alice and then
Caption: Alice can use that to encrypt the
Caption: message and then you know the identity
Caption: of the recipient is whoever's got that
Caption: private key that's why you need to keep
Caption: the private key private because if you
Caption: give it to anyone else they could
Caption: impersonate you and that's kind of the
Caption: opposite of what we want we don't want
Caption: to validate the recipient of the message
Caption: we want to validate the sender of the
Caption: message so to do that
Caption: instead use Alice's public and private
Caption: keys and she can give her public key to
Caption: Bob encrypted the message with her
Caption: private key and Bob can decrypt it or
Caption: validate it with the public key and in
Caption: doing that it means that only Alice
Caption: could possibly have sent that message
Caption: because she's the only one who has the
Caption: ferrata key now in our case you could
Caption: replace Alice with the Authenticator and
Caption: Bob with the website server so it's
Caption: essentially what we're doing here we'll
Caption: send up a public key signed some
Caption: information and the server can use that
Caption: public key to validate it so the web
Caption: authentication API is pretty new you
Caption: might be wondering if you can use it so
Caption: you go to the de-facto Docs of the
Caption: internet MDM and you see this graph with
Caption: a bit of green in a bit of red and you
Caption: wonder is that filling the whole story
Caption: you know I see ie in there and opera I
Caption: don't know many people who use those by
Caption: default so you got a slightly different
Caption: lens in the data and you can go there
Caption: can I use the
Caption: come and this shows the relative usage
Caption: of each browser in terms of a height of
Caption: the column each browser is a different
Caption: age different column is a different
Caption: browser and the color of the column
Caption: represents whether it's supportive or
Caption: not what's important about this view is
Caption: that there's a lot more green than red
Caption: so globally it's available for basically
Caption: two thirds I think it's sixty eight
Caption: point eight eight percent when I checked
Caption: it last Thursday or something so it's
Caption: cool looks like a lot of people could
Caption: use this thing but then you got to think
Caption: about your local demographic as well and
Caption: that regard
Caption: Australia is special so all those people
Caption: with iPhones we now have a big red
Caption: column and there's actually more red
Caption: than blue more rather than green on this
Caption: slide
Caption: roughly forty five percent of people in
Caption: Australia can use it at the moment now
Caption: it gives us new things have been
Caption: changing so I'll have a look at how
Caption: that's been changing over time we start
Caption: our little story in 2015 when edge first
Caption: released experimental support for
Caption: something like the web authentication
Caption: API it didn't exist at the time but it's
Caption: basically the same principle then
Caption: because they were doing that and I
Caption: started working with the w3c and Mozilla
Caption: and Fido we started getting some
Caption: progress and we had an actual
Caption: specification in 2016 of our August edge
Caption: released a spec compliant version that
Caption: was again behind a feature flag and I
Caption: had a little bit of a break nothing
Caption: happened in 2017 and we get into 2018
Caption: and about March or April Firefox enabled
Caption: it before the hardware of indicators in
Caption: the external ones so that's cool we'll
Caption: finally got another browser and it's on
Caption: by default the same month chrome did the
Caption: same thing and then Dropbox enabled
Caption: using it as a second factor for logging
Caption: into their websites and then chrome
Caption: supported the on platform ones that you
Caption: fingerprint like Windows hello were you
Caption: touch ID on your Mac and then edge
Caption: released it by default in November so
Caption: you've already had a bit happening but
Caption: you still can't really use that platform
Caption: of Education so come to this year then
Caption: in May
Caption: that's very much Firefox and I will
Caption: platform dedication w3c moved the spec
Caption: to a recommendation which is basically
Caption: the final stage of a spec Safari engines
Caption: experimental support on Mac OS not on
Caption: iOS Android in April and they will all
Caption: Android devices 7 plus to act as those
Caption: hardware platform with indicators so if
Caption: you did do the demo on an Android it
Caption: would have worked well today if you do
Caption: it as well
Caption: and chrome actually started support
Caption: another manager as well which I guess
Caption: was kind of required for those that's
Caption: both happen so then you get to this
Caption: point where you look at it today and if
Caption: you're using Chrome or Firefox the
Caption: situation is pretty good you can use the
Caption: external authenticators all the internal
Caption: authenticators on any device except for
Caption: iOS and you guys yeah there's still a
Caption: few gaps but if you went back a year it
Caption: looked more like this and you couldn't
Caption: use those at all now as we were talking
Caption: about before
Caption: a lot more people had finds smartphones
Caption: where your login with their fingerprint
Caption: than the external authenticators so this
Caption: is really where we need to focus and the
Caption: fact that we've gone from nothing to
Caption: this in a year is pretty good
Caption: one day iOS will turn on the same thing
Caption: that Android did that sunny day in April
Caption: and then we'll go from roughly 30% of
Caption: people being able to use it with the
Caption: platform of indicator up to say 70
Caption: because iPhones are pretty good with
Caption: having a little fragmentation between
Caption: different regions so you can look at
Caption: this and go cool you know it's got
Caption: reasonable support now it's growing
Caption: there are a few little quirks some
Caption: browsers support different things to
Caption: others it's not really important what
Caption: all these boxes are but the red is not
Caption: supported and the yellow is in
Caption: development and you see there are a few
Caption: little boxes on each thing nothing is
Caption: completely grained
Caption: so there are a few little quirks along
Caption: the way so we've had a little bit of a
Caption: roller coaster there I don't know why
Caption: they're wearing VR goggles I think if
Caption: you're on a roller coaster the VR
Caption: goggles are just gonna confuse you more
Caption: but basically by coming to today's talk
Caption: you can say that you like to web orphan
Caption: before it was cool which has its own
Caption: little roller coaster so this is a view
Caption: of like early adopters and innovators in
Caption: the early majority that kind of thing
Caption: and showing how how the actual
Caption: percentage that some who's used changes
Caption: over time
Caption: now I would say we're right in this
Caption: early adopters phase like I said we're
Caption: at thirty percent you could kind of draw
Caption: a line there and that would roughly at
Caption: that point so I like to be an early
Caption: adopter but hey Lily McGarry is cool too
Caption: and basically you can still build this
Caption: thing and offer it to users it's not
Caption: going to take anything away from your
Caption: existing users but it does give
Caption: something you to these you do want to
Caption: give it to so how do I do that well
Caption: there's a JavaScript API like everything
Caption: it's actually surprisingly simple this
Caption: API there's a public key credential you
Caption: can look for which will tell you if it's
Caption: supported by the browser you can use
Caption: this it's a mouthful is user verifying
Caption: platform Authenticator available and
Caption: that will tell you if their device
Caption: itself can act as a platform within a
Caption: cable so for example that'll tell you if
Caption: you're using actually the device has
Caption: Windows hello or touch ID or if these
Caption: guys think your friend on moist new
Caption: phones that's gonna be the case and a
Caption: lot of new devices have that too that's
Caption: cool then you've got registration
Caption: through Windows navigator credentials
Caption: create with some options and getting
Caption: that credential with kinda choice don't
Caption: get again with emotions we don't really
Caption: have time to talk about what those are
Caption: essentially that's the information
Caption: they've got sent between the different
Caption: parts so if you've got something from
Caption: your server you would pass that through
Caption: to the Authenticator and that's been
Caption: basically the same information if you
Caption: want to look go to web orphaned dot
Caption: guide which is associated with with web
Caption: orphan do I owe I think the whole thing
Caption: is built like you were so how do you
Caption: make it better for users so if I'm
Caption: telling you that you can actually start
Caption: building this today what do you need to
Caption: do to make it
Caption: well you've got a few account management
Caption: flaws to consider you know anyway you
Caption: would have used the password and they
Caption: need to think about what you're gonna do
Caption: instead so you've got things like
Caption: registration
Caption: you've got login credential management
Caption: and account recovery account recovery is
Caption: a big one that we'll discuss but we'll
Caption: get into the other ones first so you can
Caption: look at your registration page and go
Caption: what information do we want to capture
Caption: you know you probably need to use a name
Caption: or email something like that you don't
Caption: need a password necessarily and you live
Caption: like a register button just go finish
Caption: the form but before we can decide
Caption: exactly what stuff you need you go to
Caption: the side if you want to use the web
Caption: authentication API to do password let's
Caption: login or as a second factor if you're
Caption: gonna do password lists you may not
Caption: require a password so you could probably
Caption: get rid of that field but at the same
Caption: time you might want to still allow
Caption: people to have a password there is
Caption: always gonna be a trade-off between
Caption: security and convenience so if you do
Caption: have a password you haven't gone quite
Caption: as far with the security side but it's
Caption: probably a better convenience for the
Caption: users because no-one's really used to
Caption: logging in with this thing yet then you
Caption: got to think about if you're gonna
Caption: register the token now or later consider
Caption: things like drop-off rates for filling
Caption: in the form if you add more friction
Caption: than people might not sign up you must
Caption: get your existing users to think about
Caption: so how do you get them to start using it
Caption: well for example you could put some
Caption: hints on the login page maybe you have a
Caption: promise that users see after they've
Caption: logged in in this case your device is
Caption: capable of logging in without a password
Caption: and see if they want to register it and
Caption: then you've got things like deciding
Caption: what kind of messages you want to
Caption: display or how forceful you want to push
Caption: people into signing up for this new
Caption: thing I guess it's all about considering
Caption: what your users doing you can have
Caption: analytics and those kind of things to
Caption: sell out as well
Caption: it's also probably going to change your
Caption: login page if you're going past
Caption: worthless if you're going past word
Caption: lists you probably don't need the
Caption: password field
Caption: but maybe you do you know maybe you give
Caption: that as an option maybe you have a
Caption: separate form for logging without a
Caption: password you can also go user nameless
Caption: which is kind of cool so you might
Caption: register with a username or not doesn't
Caption: really matter but your similar
Caption: authenticators can actually handle
Caption: storing keys on the device that you can
Caption: just look up so you get a browser prompt
Caption: there are more conditions to meet if you
Caption: want to do this and the browser support
Caption: isn't as good that's one of those quirks
Caption: at the moment today it's only supported
Caption: an edge but the next versions of Chrome
Caption: and Firefox will support that as well
Caption: and maybe you want to fall back to using
Caption: a password even if they are using
Caption: password let's login normally then you
Caption: think about things like managing those
Caption: devices you know you might have one
Caption: Authenticator if you do buy a UV key or
Caption: whatever you probably want to get to and
Caption: then you can keep one on you so you can
Caption: use it all the time
Caption: another one is it backup that you keep
Caption: in a drawer at home or whatever in case
Caption: you lose it
Caption: so you gotta figure out where someone's
Caption: gonna go to manage those how you'll
Caption: identify those in it authenticated is on
Caption: that page you know maybe you've got
Caption: things like the date you last you still
Caption: of the day you added it so that you can
Caption: decide if it hasn't been used in a while
Caption: maybe you want to plate it and maybe
Caption: further use it in a while you want to
Caption: prompt them to remove it
Caption: you know for their own security if they
Caption: don't have that thing anymore that's the
Caption: way they can log into their account so
Caption: you might want to from them to get rid
Caption: of it if they don't have it another
Caption: consideration at this point is if you
Caption: only have a platform with indicator
Caption: registered you can actually log in on
Caption: any other device so that's where the
Caption: password comes in is quite useful thing
Caption: to have so what if I don't have a device
Caption: yeah maybe let them login with a
Caption: password or think about some other way
Caption: you can let them login for example slack
Caption: is like a magic link you could send you
Caption: could do something similar if you're
Caption: gonna do that then you got to make sure
Caption: you've got their email address and if
Caption: they have got an email address you
Caption: probably wanna make sure you've verified
Caption: their email address otherwise
Caption: just enter the wrong one and I can log
Caption: into your account or whatever other
Caption: people done in this case you know I
Caption: don't want to be the first person to
Caption: build this thing I'm already not yes a
Caption: payment to it but a lot of the big
Caption: players like Google and Facebook and
Caption: github Twitter Dropbox have all
Caption: influence of this in some fashion
Caption: Microsoft accounts and that kind of
Caption: thing as well they've all kind of copped
Caption: out and gone for it as a second factor I
Caption: can understand it because there are a
Caption: lot more things to consider if you're
Caption: gonna go pass wordless like we're just
Caption: talking about but basically you go into
Caption: there you eyes and it looks something
Caption: like this you have two factor
Caption: authentication you have your devices you
Caption: can edit remove them change add
Caption: nicknames to them so it's all pretty
Caption: standard stuff and I guess but
Caption: two-factor authentication that works
Caption: really well for them because they've
Caption: already got things like falling back to
Caption: sending an SMS if you don't have your
Caption: device on you so a lot of those things
Caption: that they would need to think about
Caption: would change how would I do it I've
Caption: asked a lot of questions along the way
Caption: and haven't really given you any answers
Caption: so as you probably do that at some point
Caption: so let's do a little bit of demo maybe
Caption: cool
Caption: a fun
Caption: cool alright let's look at this right
Caption: now super weird let's assume I'm already
Caption: a user of this website will call it way
Caption: bought them because taro says so I might
Caption: decide that I want to login with my
Caption: password because I have an existing
Caption: account and then I get into this page
Caption: probably what I'll do from there is
Caption: check if I have a registered
Caption: Authenticator at some code at the bottom
Caption: here pseudo code eesh
Caption: you can't say we're up to clear those
Caption: variables for example but basically
Caption: you'll go see if they've already got one
Caption: registered or if they've ignored this
Caption: prompt before you won't show it to them
Caption: then you can use that feature detection
Caption: there is user verifying he's a user
Caption: verifying platform with indicator
Caption: available so check if it's available if
Caption: it's not then you can't do anything if
Caption: it is share them a prompt so we'll see
Caption: what that looks like I've hooked up to
Caption: this little button because I had to I
Caption: couldn't show I scared away at this year
Caption: to code so now you get that prompt the
Caption: same form for showed you before pretty
Caption: much you have a device name and register
Caption: button remind me later if I enter a name
Caption: like Windows I don't show you what the
Caption: code would roughly be so for example
Caption: when I click cancel
Caption: I'll start selling your local stories to
Caption: remind me later or something like that
Caption: when I want to register that's the more
Caption: interesting part so in that case I will
Caption: do make a request to the server to get
Caption: that challenge and the Authenticator
Caption: details the relying party details all
Caption: that kind of stuff then I will basically
Caption: do some transformations on that data
Caption: because I get Jason can't send array
Caption: buffers but the API actually expects
Caption: array buffers I don't know why they made
Caption: it harder to use but they did I guess
Caption: maybe they're more secure or something
Caption: oh it's smaller I guess so
Caption: I get those options and I pass them
Caption: through to window dot navigated
Caption: credential we still create and once
Caption: that's been created or get back a
Caption: response from the Authenticator
Caption: essentially which will maybe be
Caption: because it can be canceled or might not
Caption: so have to check for that in my response
Caption: handling then I will send through the
Caption: credential by the public key and the
Caption: current ID to the server get back a
Caption: response from them and says they've
Caption: stored it and all that jazz and if that
Caption: was successful I closed the prompt it's
Caption: not that much code really like this is
Caption: kind of all I would have in the app in
Caption: terms of register gonna make that a
Caption: reasonable function some way so could
Caption: president a few pages we're gonna go
Caption: ahead and register that and this is the
Caption: prompt they get so I have a PIN number
Caption: NATO info I could get my Kiva that's
Caption: more annoying is your thing and we're
Caption: done normally you'd probably want to
Caption: show things like your own prompt to
Caption: explain to the user what's going to
Caption: happen you know that they're going to
Caption: get a prompt from their Authenticator
Caption: and then after we she probably wanted
Caption: success message or something for the
Caption: sake of this demo assume that was there
Caption: and then you look at things like
Caption: managing your credentials so I go to my
Caption: account and then click on this world
Caption: credentials link I can see a list of
Caption: credentials that I already have
Caption: registered you'll notice that the
Caption: windows one isn't there because it's a
Caption: demo so I didn't bother looking it up
Caption: but you're still see everything you
Caption: might need so I look at this and go oh
Caption: you the key five see I'm using it well
Caption: but I still own it so I'll keep it and
Caption: NFC actually lost
Caption: so it's removed and that's gone I want
Caption: to add a new one so like that forget my
Caption: prompt a quick of this particular one I
Caption: guess is it it prompts you for part of
Caption: the platform one if you have it unless
Caption: you tell it not to so I didn't tell them
Caption: not to forget that I gotta click cancel
Caption: that and then see what happens so I can
Caption: insert my security key took my many USB
Caption: ports that are not taken up by other
Caption: adapters
Caption: I've got a pin on this that's an
Caption: optional thing you can set up with your
Caption: device
Caption: I recommend it because then you can use
Caption: it as those two factors if I didn't have
Caption: a pin I just need to press the button on
Caption: it so that's not as secure and the pin
Caption: is pretty low friction as well so I'll
Caption: go ahead and answer that yes and no no
Caption: touch the button so big yellow button on
Caption: it I press that let's say oh that took
Caption: this is actually the NFC one that I
Caption: removed either back that's basically it
Caption: there's not a huge amount to it you know
Caption: let's say I log out and show you in
Caption: login with that device if it wants to
Caption: work so I've got my username I'd need to
Caption: enter that still and they can click
Caption: login it's pretty much the same thing
Caption: I'll get a prompt you can see what I've
Caption: been testing so it's showing me all the
Caption: criminals that have registered for this
Caption: site and the many usernames and that
Caption: kind of thing
Caption: so here it's got this way Bothan
Caption: workshop that's that display name that I
Caption: said from the relying party I come for
Caption: you how to delete these by the way so I
Caption: would have thought I couldn't figure it
Caption: out let's say I want to sign in as a
Caption: feel Eric you don't see he's never got
Caption: there okay again it's of a pin everyone
Caption: loves a good pin we're in so that is
Caption: pretty much how I would do it and we're
Caption: gonna go just one step further and we'll
Caption: talk about what we talked about because
Caption: that's what we're doing these things I
Caption: talked a little bit about the problems
Caption: with how we do with indication now you
Caption: know we're sending secrets over the
Caption: Internet which means that those secrets
Caption: can be taken by somebody else are we
Caption: talking about how web authentication is
Caption: better for us because the supports
Caption: growing and you don't need to have a
Caption: password so that's cool to the state of
Caption: where Bothan where it's supported where
Caption: it's not supported iOS is unlucky
Caption: actually on that iOS 13 is coming out in
Caption: like September
Caption: probably that doesn't support either
Caption: thanks Apple but hopefully that'll be in
Caption: like 13.1 or something because Mac OS 13
Caption: or Safari 13 on whichever version they
Caption: do will support by default so this
Caption: talked earlier about the thing behind a
Caption: feature flag the next version of Safari
Caption: which is probably also September will
Caption: have that enabled by default so you know
Caption: we got better again it's just iOS now
Caption: that we need a wait for everyone else is
Caption: fine what you see both that they well
Caption: roughly that I mean if you want to
Caption: follow Google instead of me which I
Caption: could completely understand you could
Caption: build it as a second factor but
Caption: otherwise go with that and I get also
Caption: gauging things to think about for
Caption: tomorrow like like its how you gonna
Caption: handle those new users or maybe you want
Caption: to think about things like when you can
Caption: get rid of passwords altogether thank
Caption: you everybody
Caption: [Applause]